look i i think that the
decision was taken by the scottish
people uh only a few years ago
in recent memory i think we should
respect that we should
also focus on uh what i think the people
of the whole of the uk scotland england
everybody wants us to look at which is
uh the economic position we're in uh the
covid uh effective coveted on the the
country and then the post covid issues
that were we're grappling with that's
the focus of the government we're
working with uh our friends in the
scottish government uh in the in the
scottish administration uh on those
issues and that's that's what you'd
expect the government to do if you want
to make a solid case of course for
staying in the european for staying in
the united kingdom wouldn't the granting
of this order though be one way of at
least
taking away the potential stick that
nicola sturgeon could have to start
beating uh the uk government around the
head with uh and not granting that i
think that the most the most important
thing we can all do uh whatever level of
government we're in in the uk whether
it's local or regional or national it's
focus on the things that people really
want us to deal with number one is the
tackling the cost of living this
government never forget is we're helping
people in the in the immediate term uh
1200 pounds for 8 million the most
vulnerable households 400 pounds for
everybody to help with the costs of of
energy that's and that that by the way
is the firepower of the uk uh exchequer
that's the that's the firepower of our
of our single uh
uk
uh treasury and i think it's a it's a
great thing we should keep going with